y una celda metal aire necesita ser
ligera para diferentes aplicaciones para
poder transferir más electrones con una
masa pequeña se investigan sodio y
calcio como a los dos potenciales que
ánodo de un gramo de cuál de estos
metales transferirá más electrones
suponiendo que el ánodo es totalmente
consumido durante la vida de la celda
justifica tu respuesta con cálculos
vayamos al principio en donde tenemos
las reacciones que involucran al sodio y
al calcio
de hecho déjenme copiar y pegar esto
para que sea más fácil y nos sirva como
referencia
voy a copiar esto
y voy a pegarlo por acá
ok lo haré un poco más pequeño para que
no ocupe mucho espacio
ahora las reacciones que nos interesan
en realidad irán en la dirección
contraria a la que van estas reacciones
parciales recuerden que cuando
analizamos nuestra fuente de energía por
acá la primera reacción parcial es la
que produce los iones hidróxido los
iones hidróxido migran hacia el lado
izquierdo y reaccionan de nuevo se
involucran en la oxidación del metal que
tengamos aquí si esto fuera zinc el
hidróxido se combina con el zinc y lo
oxida y esos electrones extras que son
liberados en la reacción viajan por el
alambre y generan la corriente pero el
hidróxido puede reaccionar o el sodio si
este metal es sodio o con calcio si este
metal fuera calcio
entonces las reacciones que nos
interesan van del lado derecho al lado
izquierdo
voy a reescribir eso
si reescribimos las cosas eso nos ayuda
a entender mejor lo que está pasando
entonces para la reacción de sodio por
cada dos moléculas de sodio sólido de
eso está formado nuestro ánodo más dos
moléculas de hidróxido que se encuentran
en solución acuosa se produce óxido de
sodio en estado sólido
más agua en estado líquido
+ 2 electrones
y esto es muy importante porque si
tenemos un gramo de cada uno de estos
metales
tenemos que saber cuántos electrones se
producirán cuántos electrones serán
transferidos a través del alambre esa es
la primera relación aquí y luego vamos a
dejar tantito al sodio y pasemos al
calcio recuerden la reacción va de
derecha a izquierda entonces vamos a
reescribir la tenemos calcio en estado
sólido + 2 hidróxidos disueltos en agua
y se produce óxido de calcio en estado
sólido más agua líquida
+ 2 electrones únicamente volvía a
escribir esta reacción pero en la
dirección opuesta y si queremos escribir
el voltaje simplemente invertimos el
signo por lo mismo de que escribimos la
reacción en la otra dirección bueno
aunque aquí no nos están preguntando por
el voltaje nos piden determinar que
ánodo de un gramo de cuál de estos
metales transferirá más electrones vamos
a ver si pensamos en el sodio en el caso
del sodio tenemos 1.0 gramos de sodio
bueno pensemos en cuántos moles de sodio
es esto
vamos a ver busquemos el sodio en la
tabla periódica
esta es la tabla que generalmente les
dan en un examen para nivel avanzado y
aquí tenemos al sodio y podemos ver su
peso atómico también actualmente
conocido como masa atómica relativa y es
la masa promedio de todas las masas
atómicas de los isótopos de sodio que se
encuentran comúnmente en la tierra si
tomáramos varias muestras de sodio y
sacamos el promedio de sus masas
atómicas ese promedio será de 22.99
entonces esto nos dice que un molde
sodio tiene una masa de 22.99 gramos o
podríamos decir que un molde sodio es
igual a 22.99 gramos entonces voy a
escribir un molde sodio
tiene una masa de 22 puntos 99 gramos
y seguimos hablando de sodio
ahora voy a asegurarme de que nos queden
molist miren si hacemos nuestro análisis
dimensional gramos / gramos o gramos de
sodio / gramos de sodio se cancelan y
nos quedan moles de sodio entonces esta
parte de la expresión me dice con
cuántos moles de sodio estamos
trabajando si tenemos un gramo de sodio
pero necesitamos pensar en cuántos
electrones cuántos electrones se podrán
transferir por eso necesitamos analizar
esta reacción entonces por cada dos
moles de sodio vamos a transferir dos
moles de electrones o dicho de otra
manera por cada mol porque aquí tenemos
una relación 2 a 2 por cada molde de
sodio vamos a transferir un molde
electrones entonces vamos a transferir
un mol
de electrones por mol de sodio
de sodio y si tenemos dos moles de sodio
tendremos dos moles de electrones si
tenemos un molde de sodio tendremos dos
no perdón si tenemos un molde de sodio
tendremos un molde de electrones bueno y
esto que nos da si multiplicamos no
esperen mejor primero veamos las
unidades los gramos de sodio se cancelan
con gramos de sodio moles de sodio se
cancelan con moles de sodio y sólo nos
quedan moles de electrones moles de
electrones y serán 1.0 por 1 entre 22 99
por 1 entonces 1.0 entre 22.99
y vamos a ver voy a usar dos cifras
significativas aquí y usemos la
calculadora entonces tenemos uno entre
22.99 y eso es igual a si tomamos en
cuenta dos cifras significativas es
aproximadamente igual a 0.0 43 entonces
esto es aproximadamente igual a 0.0 43
moles de electrones y esos son muchos
electrones porque recuerden que un mol
es aproximadamente 6.022 por 10 a la 23
son muchísimos electrones que vamos a
transferir si tenemos un gramo de sodio
ok ahora hagamos lo mismo pero con el
calcio entonces tenemos calcio
y hacemos lo mismo tenemos un gramo de
calcio
por un molde calcio ya que masa equivale
cuántos gramos tiene un molde calcio
bueno veamos la tabla periódica
aquí tenemos calcio y su masa atómica es
de 40.0 8 o ya como dicen actualmente su
masa atómica relativa que es el promedio
de la masa de todos los isótopos comunes
es de 40.0 8 vamos a escribir 40.08 y
después en nuestra reacción por cada
molde calcio cuántos moles de electrones
se producen bueno en esta reacción
tenemos que por cada calcio se producen
dos electrones entonces por cada molde
calcio tenemos dos moles de electrones
aquí escribimos por dos moles de
electrones por cada molde calcio
como lo tenemos en la reacción y esto es
aproximadamente igual a vamos a ver
primero a las unidades gramos de calcio
se cancelan con gramos de calcio moles
de calcio se cancelan con moles de
calcio y entonces tenemos uno por uno
entre 40.08 por dos que es igual a 2
entre 40.08 y eso es vamos a ver dos
entre 40.08 y de nuevo quiero que
tomemos en cuenta dos cifras
significativas porque este 2 y éstos uno
son números puros entonces dos entre eso
es igual a cero punto cero 50 entonces
0.0 50 moles de electrones ya con este
cálculo podemos ver que un gramo de
calcio puede transferir más electrones
que un gramo de sodio si el ánodo fuera
de sodio entonces claramente podemos ver
que el calcio bueno
un gramo de calcio puede transferir
puede transferir más electrones más
electrones
un gramo de sodio
sodio y lo podemos ver aquí porque ya
hicimos el cálculo